[Music]
so nice to have you here so glad to be
back congratulations uh you're having
all this success uh people really uh
they love you you're going places
uh and and you are rubbing elbows with
some important people i understand
is this not correct that you've been
helping out mr brad pitt with one of his
causes is that right he has this really
cool charity uh called make it right and
they rebuild homes in the lower ninth
ward in new orleans and it's a really
great cause
and they asked me uh to come down there
and uh host this after party for this
event they had and i was like sure what
do you want me to do and like could you
like maybe introduce some of the
musicians at the after party like could
you maybe introduce seal and i was like
wait a second
i get to say whatever i want and then
seal is going to pop up yes i'm doing
this
that sounds cool yeah so i i go to the
event
and uh i'm backstage with seal and you
know i'm not on seal's radar still
doesn't know who i am and i go up to
introduce them and this is what i did i
said uh ladies and gentlemen
our next performer he's running a little
bit late so he wanted to know if maybe i
could sing one of his hit songs for him
to kill some time
so i guess there's nothing left to say
but
[Laughter]
[Music]
almost here sorry i can't hear you there
used to be a graying tower alone on the
what's that seals here i feel like at
this point maybe i should just finish my
version
and i just did that for way too long
right and
seal finally came up and he didn't even
say anything he just put his arm around
my shoulder and was just like
i get it because you know seal doesn't
know i'm a comedian or anything he just
thinks i'm some crazy brown man that's
like seizing the moment to like audition
for seal and like sign the walrus
records or whatever and
starting my r b career as the brown
penguin and uh so i get it
well did you have a good time at least
at the party did you get to hang out at
the party yeah i i they had a party and
i hung out with steel a little bit and
talked to him for a little while and
he's a really cool guy like the way he
talks and everything's so beautiful like
i was standing in an elevator with this
woman and he looks over at us he goes
my only regret
is i do not have a photograph to capture
this moment forever
and i was like
oh my god
seal
i wanna [ __ ] you wow
that was beautiful
no one talks to me like that
and then i realized like all his song
lyrics those aren't song lyrics that's
just the way he talks
like he goes to the optometrist uptown
was like see what's wrong with your eyes
he's like did you know that when it
snows my eyes become wide and the alive
sia what are you talking about
you're like a dinner party with seal
like steel how's that chicken
i compare it to a kiss from the room
the rice joins my food on the plate
yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum
[Music]
[Applause]
but it was a cool event they had a
charity auction too
and they had like some i drank some wine
at the charity auction and i may have
drank a little bit too much wine because
uh the next morning i woke up and i was
like oh my god what did i do last night
and we all have those moments you're
like oh what did i do but i think i had
the best one because i woke up and i was
like
oh what did i do last night
i think i bid and want an auction to be
an extra in the next tyler perry movie
and that is true you really did yes me
and a friend of my choice get to be an
extra in the next tyler perry movie so
next summer when you're watching madea
goes to jail 2 and you see me and seal
in the background
we gotta take a break